My name is Nick Mason and I’m a musician
and I’ve played drums for Pink Floyd for
the last fifity years but I am also a fanatical
racing enthusiast, I think we could say.
I’ve been coming to Goodwood since the first
hill climb, twenty, er, I don’t know how
long ago it was.
And I am still enjoying it today.
It’s completely different now.
The first time the were no demonstrations,
it was a straight hill climb.
Everyone was timed in different
classes and it was wonderful.
And it’s now still wonderful but it’s completely different it’s become the new motor show.
I never wanted to be a car collector I wanted
to go motor racing and what happened was that,
thanks to the success of the records I end up being able to keep everything I’ve ever raced.
I bought the Ferrari 250 GTO about forty, forty-something years ago.
Everyone thought I was completely insane,
including myself I think.
But now they think I am sort of the Warren
Buffett of motoring.
I’ve had the car so long now, it is part of the family.
I’m so familiar with it, I absolutely recognize
the view out of it but I still think
it is one of the greatest views that you can possibly have.
Rather that great geographical landscapes,
that beautiful bonnet stretching ahead
is a wonderful thing.
I remember when I was quite young, seeing
one of these cars at Goodwood and peering into it and thinking,
“Oh it’d be great to be in there and
doing that.”
As a driver’s car it’s fantastic but it’s also then got a sprinkle of real history, and
it’s part of Ferrari history and part of Le Mans
which to me has always been for me the great race.